dans quelques mois la ruem Albus de
brapanon sera totalement
métamorphosée en attendant ces résidents
doivent s'accommoder des bulles d'oser
et des mes de terre
mais les travaux actuels n'effil pas le
souvenir d'
albiusver mé pour féc la
Vancouver secret de la
vanille
Edmond Albius et brapanon ont la vanille
en commun Edmond esclave perd sa mère à
sa naissance en 1829 à saintesusanne il
est recueilli par feréolle baaumont
bélier établi à belleevue qui s'y
attache comme à un fils il l'emmène
souvent dans son verger et lui transmet
sa passion des plantes en 1841 le jeune
Edmond découvre ainsi une méthode
manuelle pour féconder la fleur de
vanill Feréol en rêvait et cela fait
déjà plusieurs années que les muséums
d'histoire naturelle de Paris et les
scientifiques locaux cherchent de leur
côté observateur l'esclave qui n'a alors
que 12 ans a repéré avant eux les
organes sexuels de l'orchidée et les a
mis en contact cette opération est
normalement effectuée par un insecte
mais celui-ci n'a pas été importé à
Bourbon avec la vanille introduite en
1819 après cette découverte l'essort de
la vanille va assurer les beaux jours de
Beaumont bélier en reconnaissance il a
franchi mont qui reçoit comme nom de
liberté à Albius qui signifie blanc en
revanche la requête du juge de paix de
sainte-susanne pour faire accorder au
jeune homme une récompense publique
restera lêre morte du coup le jeune
homme démuni mais habitué à vivre
confortablement commet un vol de bijoux
lors d'un voyage à Saint-Denis il est
condamné à 5 ans de réclusion et à la
chaîne mais bénéficiera d'une remise de
peine pour bonne conduite il retourne à
saint-tesusanne où il se marie il meurt
le 9 août 1880 à l'hôpital communal de
sainte-susanne